hello how do it me how you good great
okay this is mostly for audio test not
for you for me great
hi guys mark here just first off the bat
my glasses broke hooray I wasn't doing
anything with them except running into a
wall repeatedly I had to do to have
multiple times because it didn't get it
right on the first tank it looked too
fake I had to make it look regal so I
really it's like I'm in the bed thing
and of course I edited it post but that
hurt a lot and I think it might have led
to the destruction of my glasses but
either way I was just wearing them
yesterday and they literally fell off of
my face and pieces like they just had
enough for the three years that I've had
these particular set of glasses it was
just alright we rounded up of this [ __ ]
oh here time to give up on life oh there
goes again so I no longer have glasses
for now I that contact boy Daphne a my
meaning hard enough for you guys I'm
really trying here so it's going to be
glasses let's mark anew for the next two
weeks because apparently the place that
I went to can't make them in house and
they have to send off for some strange
material that they get from space in
order to make the lenses for my glasses
because I have really [ __ ] up eyes my
eyes if I don't control them they'll
just pop out of my head and go wandering
off in different directions of course
that's not true it's an exaggeration
it's what we in the business call
hyperbole or a goddamn lie but back to
the crux of this vlog I wanted to talk
about something very specific and very
near and dear to my heart which is the
topic of stress because this past week
has been a bit of a hell for me I was in
DC for a long time have you been I was
stuck at the airport over and over and
over and over again and I made a vlog
about this that kind of roasted Delta a
little bit because they really screwed
me
/ like it wasn't that like I get it
they're computer systems went down but
it wasn't that that really screwed me
over and it was that they continually
rebooked me on flights that were then
subsequently canceled I I didn't I know
I could have rebooked on another airline
I could have done that that would have
been easy for me but if I had done they
promised me that they would go and I
trusted them why it's partially my fault
because I trusted them when obviously
they were having horrible computer
issues but everyone I talked to was so
adamant that I would be flying home on
the next plane I even patiently waited
the first day because I was like oh it's
okay I'll hang out with Bob for another
day and then by day three he was sick of
me not good company to be around for
that long so stress and the lack thereof
in my life because one of the great
things that came out of that trip
besides the charity latching which was
extremely successful and thank you
everyone who joined in on that stream
but the other great thing that came out
of that weekend was two discoveries of
mine and they're more rediscoveries more
than they are discoveries themselves but
number one that crap vlog I made that
was one of the most fun videos I've done
in a long time because it was just me
Bob his wife his brother-in-law and all
four of us just going out on the town
bringing a camera with us and just being
stupid and having fun out in the real
world with real people and real sunlight
lots of real stuff out there it was cool
it was so good just to be able to go out
and do stuff and you know I'm not saying
that I dislike doing gaming videos or
even doing this strange vlog that's in
my bathroom that I've been doing and has
become a habit of mine I should probably
break it but the lighting so good so I
can't really ignore it but
kind of unearthed this potential and I
hope to do more stuff like that in the
future I really do my buddy Tyler is
actually moving to LA you guys know
Tyler no or Tyler stone-faced Tyler he
has no face [ __ ] but my buddy Tyler he's
moving to LA in just a few weeks and
together I fully intend to go out more
and do more stuff and even meet fans
because every time I go out now like
someone comes up to me and recognizes me
for my videos and I'm honored to meet
him and maybe now when people come up to
me they can be in videos too I would be
super cool it would be really awesome to
be able to go out there and meet these
people and then have them also pick
featured in these random stupid logs
that I do like that'd be awesome I would
love that and the second thing that I
kind of rediscovered about what I love
about YouTube is doing stupid little
sketches and the Delta one was I mean
actually it was but in all honesty it
was shot in like no light it was done on
Bob's little camcorder with the
camcorder audio so surprisingly good for
what it was and then the special but
special effects was just I hope this
works I have no idea if it's gonna blend
and we just did it and it was fun we did
it in like two hours and it took three
hours to edit and then they're like oh
we just ran to CVS to get stupid
supplies because we didn't know how to
make like a a mask that said dealt on it
so we just literally got cardboard paper
and turteltaub ended it was awesome
and that was fun it was so fun and then
lately I've just been you know for fun
I've been doing these other stupid crap
videos and I love it I love it I love it
I love doing these things I love them oh
it's so much oh you guys don't know how
much her how happy it makes me when I
make these videos and again
not saying I dislike doing gaming videos
but it's like this little bit of passion
to let me let out this stupid in my soul
I have to channel it somehow or else is
gonna build up inside me and turn into
rage that's not good so it's fun and
coming back to the topic of stress is
what I'm trying to say is I came out of
a very stressful situation and I turned
it into something really creative for
myself so I may have suffered at the
hands of forces beyond my control but
out of it came some really cool things
and some cooler things that I think you
will like in the future it's gonna be a
fun fun time going forward when Tyler
gets here I cannot wait to show you the
stupid it's an remember it was show you
how many stupid ideas we together can
make and it's going to be a hundred
percent awesome and it's going to be a
hundred percent more cool stuff for you
guys so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye